we are joined now by dr atul gawandi he
is a surgeon at brigham and women's
hospital in boston and a professor at
the harvard
t.h chan school of public health he's
also a member of president-elect biden's
coronavirus advisory board
good morning dr gwandy thanks for
joining us
good morning dr gwandy if so far we
vaccinated
two million people or at least they've
received that first dose that sounds
like a big number but really we're
behind schedule operation warp
speed said that they wanted to vaccinate
20 million people by this time by the
end of the year
what will the incoming biden
administration do not just to catch up
but to go faster
there's going to be a ton to do and we
still don't have all of the information
that's required to understand where the
bottlenecks are if there are ingredient
shortages to make the viru
the vaccines then then we will
invoke the defense production act if
necessary to generate the
ingredients needed if this is a problem
of distribution
then we're going to need to understand
where the bottlenecks are there's so
many
steps along the way that are critical
and the reality is
it's one administration time but come
january 20 i think the biden
administration will be
will be much more transparent and clear
about
where the challenges are and what the
opportunities are and how we're going to
solve them
i know there are still a lot of unknowns
from your perspective but the
hhs secretary alex azar said that by
june of 2021
anyone who wants to be vaccinated should
be able to be vaccinated
do you think that is still a realistic
timeline
i'm worried about over promising on when
things are going to be able to be
uh back to normal the
you have to build in that there are
going to be hitches in this process and
we're
already seeing it in the in the last in
the first couple weeks getting started
i think the realistic picture is to
expect that
it could be fall before things are
really enough people are being
vaccinated that we're getting back to
normal
and that it might be summer before the
general public is really accessing the
vaccine
the blind administration will do
everything possible to
accelerate this process but i think we
have to be straight with people we've
been consistently
underestimating the virus and uh and
over promising what will be accomplished
and that has to change
now talking about astrazeneca of course
that vaccine's been making
a lot of news the uk is expected to
approve it any day now
but initial data said it was less
less effective than the pfizer and the
moderna vaccines now astrazeneca is
saying it's just as effective
how unusual is it to see a change in
efficacy like that
it's it's confusing to be honest there
there were
the early reports were that there were
two different doses one that wasn't as
effective as another which was at 90
percent
now they say that they have a 90
effective uh
dose regimen that's possible this is a
reputable
um oxford group created the vaccine and
and uh and astrazeneca is a reputable
pharmaceutical company but
but you know at this point we really
have to see the data to trust that this
is
true and it would be a huge boon to have
a third vaccine
available especially one this one is is
a tenth the cost of the current vaccines
dr atul gawandi thank you so much